Hello there and welcome,
again we are broadcasting from
the Largo Theater in Los Angeles and
here's how we're doing
the shows as I said,
I have just a skeleton
crew very few people here.
Everyone's been tested,
everyone's socially distance
and the audience is empty except
for my trusty assistant Sona Movsesian.
How you doing there Sona?
I'm fine.
Yesterday was our first
show from the Largo
how do you think it went?
I think it went great.
It's just as good as having
200 people here laughing.
It's pretty much the same thing.
Don't you think Sona?
Yeah.
Anyway, these are strange times
as you can see Sona is wearing a mask.
It's probably why you
can't hear her laughter
and her cheering.
I wear a mask all the time,
except when I'm broadcasting,
everyone here is wearing a mask and
that's what's strange though,
is that that's,
that should be what everyone's doing.
Everyone should be wearing a mask,
but as Coronavirus
cases continue to spike.
States are really struggling to get people
to wear face masks in public.
You know we've already seen companies
selling mask with personalized
logos that's happening.
Well, here's the latest
now State Governments
are getting in the game by
issuing exclusive vanity masks.
Yeah these are one of a kind mask
with a personalized message.
Just like vanity license plates.
Yeah this is true.
Here are some I saw today.
Here's one, I've had sex.
Strange, odd good for you i guess.
Look at this one beef breath
not bragging i don't think.
Look at this one creepy
adult pacifier on other side.
Probably good to know.
Yeah here's this one is this right?
The answer is no, that is not right.
Check out this one
warning have soul patch.
I don't know why it's
not a complete sentence.
It could have been I have a soul patch.
What are you the Hulk?
Either way no one wants to know.
And finally, here's a mask
I think it's terrific,
mask matches the carpet.
I've had some success with that one.
I don't even know what I mean by success.
(chuckling)